we're still in the early stages of what
everyone now agrees is a severe economic
crisis how severe weather different
estimates going around this is what the
obr said just recently quarterly
economic growth is so this is quarterly
growth of UK economy national output
going all the way back to 1920 so that
line is how much is going up and down
you can see the 1920s depression
actually worse than the 30s in the UK
you can see World War two a little break
in the statistics financial crisis look
at this line and let's add on what the
obr thinks the impact of kovat 19 could
well be an extraordinary fall that would
be the biggest quarterly for we've ever
seen 35 percent and the striking thing
is Andrew Bailey governor the Bank of
England thinks this is plausible he's
looked at the data that they're getting
in early data on the UK economy and
think that might well actually turn out
to be right and here's the waring thing
the obr thinks the economy could bounce
back in the next few quarters but Andrew
Bailey says they're not quite sure about
that it may well be that's even worse
than what the OPR is sketching out we'll
see what they provide in their forecasts
but at the same time we've had all sorts
of different measures from the
government they've extended the furlough
scheme to support workers in different
companies why are they doing that it's
partly because of data like this this
shows you unemployment claims benefits
claims going all the way back to the
early 1980s we've had this chawl once
before but it's so striking it's worth
bringing out again you can see it has
never been as high with not in the 80s
not in black wednesday nighta to
financial crisis we've never seen as
many unemployment claims as we are
getting at the moment through universal
credit a really striking increase
showing just how severe the economic
crisis in the UK is how severe is it
compared with other countries well the
IMF looked at that earlier on this week
downgrading many countries around the
world this shows you how much percentage
points they downgraded different
countries for their GDP growth in the
year were at the moment so 2020 you can
see China although China just released
the worst GDP numbers they've had in
decades it's still actually one of the
smallest downgrades of any country Japan
down there as well do you K down by 7.9
percentage points so is the US but look
Germany down downgraded by even more
than the UK even though many think that
it's dealt with over from 19 very well
France down by 0.5 and Italy down by 9.6
percent percentage points downgrade an
enormous downgrade and the worry is
that may only be the start of it because
many people the IMF included the Bank of
England included think that there could
well be more downgrades to come